we don't teach history in schools so the
fact that we we convince black history
all in one month when black history is
American history it's like we do
ourselves a disservice not only for not
only for the legacy of black people but
we've actually contributed to its
country but for the perspective of white
people to know you know that this is
their history as well that the things
that were done to black people is what
is the white legacy I'm Taylor Brooks
and these are conversations about
defining one's relationship to blackness
and how that defines their America okay
Malcolm so I am starting all of these
with the exact same question which is
when did you realize that being black
was different from being white I didn't
realize it probably into the third grade
because I was started school at a
private school was all black in the City
of Newark New Jersey was called Chad
school and I laugh down because I'm like
it was almost like they were it was like
a Academy for Black Panthers or
something like every day was Sunday
black national anthem every day was
Black History Month we call it everybody
brother or sister that's how we
addressed our teachers and it was like
they just taught you so much about your
you know your heritage I haven't cried
in being black and I'm like how to work
as a community and so I was there from
pre-k until 2nd grade and then in third
grade I moved to Piscataway New Jersey
where and I spent the rest of my time
and went to public school and it was you
know a stark difference all the way from
just not seeing any black teachers in
front of you to the curriculum you know
being totally different to even like I
said the national anthem of what you saw
to some kind of every day those routines
and rituals we're totally different and
I think that representation that's who
usually said I was used to seeing was no
longer there and I think that's kind of
when I began to see the difference
between you know something that I was
like so proud of
kind of honoring going into a different
situation and seeing it not necessarily
be held to that same regard and I would
say most black people probably did not
have that experience you know when
they're younger being surrounded by
black people but also blackness but I do
want to talk about why there is a need
for exclusively black spaces because I
think that some white people might hear
this and say well that's dividing us
having you at a school that is only with
black people but it's the same thing I
say when I would hear white people will
say that the TV show blackish was racist
and that black is actually isn't racist
and you guys have plenty programs that
are whitish they're just called things
like friends or Seinfeld are sex in the
city and since the world has been so
catered to white people and what what
people like to consume you don't need
the things to explicitly be called black
because everything is white so you don't
have to name it as white even think
about like we talked about when we name
different groups of people in America we
say african-american we say Asian
American Latin American all of these
different types of American but when we
talk about white then white people is
just American because we've always kind
of had that idea that white is
synonymous with American yeah like white
needs no - they mean well - in their
identity yeah yeah you know especially
for black people we oftentimes don't
have a lot of those safe spaces you know
we look at even even from like a
commerce and business standpoint you go
to almost every major city in the
country you'll have a chinatown you'll
have a Little Italy you'll have these
pockets where different you know
ethnicities
you know have these spaces that they can
retreat to they do business with each
other and it's not exclusive you know
it's not like people can't come into
those communities but out of those are
there spaces and I felt like black
people don't really have those kind of
spaces and so I think it's important for
us to create a Mundell it was important
for me to even like start
my education in a space like that the
you know and I have friends that I've
you know known since kindergarten and
all of those kind of had that same
framework and perspective on our
blackness on history and culture and we
see the difference between us and our
peers who had different experiences yeah
and going off that I don't remember the
exact article in the ins and outs of it
but it was discussing how a lot of other
like races and ethnicities have things
like time in town a little italy and
things like that but the black
neighborhoods and the black communities
don't have those because the dollar
circulates one day and leaves the next
day whereas in those other smaller
communities like china tell italy the
dollar stays there for like a year what
we used to have those things and that's
that's the one thing that I had to learn
is I asked that same question why don't
we have like like our neighborhoods the
hood like we don't own anything in it
like we either dollar leaves the
neighborhood you know why can't we build
these things and and that's when my
family kind of taught me about black
Wall Street in Tulsa Oklahoma in 1921
and other communities like it and a lot
of those communities during the Jim Crow
South where they didn't really have much
nothing near the freedoms that we had
today they were still building worlds
they were building their own businesses
huge communities were literally they had
all classes of people from wealthy black
folks all the way down to the working
class and they kept that that money into
their communities and unfortunately
almost all of those neighborhood has met
the same fate and there was on the
burner down or violently dispossessed
from black people and really never
recovered and so you know that's that's
one of those things when we look at by
today's context we like don't black
people have these spaces like we you
almost you'll think that we are doing
something to you know that what we
aren't doing something like everybody
else when really if you know our history
we've done this probably better than
anybody else and have just had it
destroyed and then you know then you had
all that a legislation and other things
that were put in place
keep it that way and now here we are in
2020 trying to figure out how to
recreate those time spaces yeah and I
mean I think and this is a thing me and
you talk often this is a thing that we
have discussed is the way that we tell
stories is important and the way that
you start stories because a lot of
people had never heard of black Wall
Street until like Russell Westbrook said
he wanted to do a documentary on and
something like what is that and it's
because if you tell the story of black
people starting with simply like
oppression right or if you tell a story
black people starting with now you're
gonna miss the context of the things
that have happened to us they disabled
us from doing many of the things that we
should be doing every day
and that takes away I think it skews the
entire story and I think in a lot of
ways has skewed the way people view
black people yeah I think that's why
we've arrived now like in a lot of white
people struggle with the idea of racism
because we've we've painted the picture
of racism to be water hoses and dogs and
call us somebody n-word and that's not
the only form of racism you know and and
there are so many other systems and that
were put in place that would that were
tied and synonymous to racism back in
the day but once we you know lost our
stomach for lynchings and hoses and dogs
those systems still stayed in place and
I think we don't teach history in
schools so the fact that we we condense
black history all in one month when
black history is American history is
like we do ourselves a disservice not
only for not only for the legacy of
black people but we've actually
contributed to this country but for the
perspective of white people to know you
know that this is their history as well
that the the things that were done to
black people is what is the white legacy
like as much as we don't like to talk
about it and even even you know places
like Tulsa Oklahoma the reason a lot of
people don't know about it is because
even the state of Oklahoma didn't even
recognize the incident until 2011 and so
it's a lot of these things are not
from historical point not things that we
want to push forward as a country and so
they're oftentimes swept under the road
and we try to have that reconciliation
without really arriving on a common
truth and so we're constantly like you
know confused why people are like I'm
not racist and I don't understand racism
and it's because they haven't been
taught about how racist systems work or
how things can be skewed or in history
and black people we know it because we
feel it but all the times we don't even
know you know what we were able to
accomplish the things that we've been
able to do what does it look like to
have those kind of group economics and
those examples because they've been a
story and we've kind of just moved on so
history we need to really focus on
history in our schools because that's I
mean that's the hardest thing about not
knowing where to goes we really don't
even understand them you said something
like that I think is very important and
that is the core of a lot of these clips
and things that we see on social media
right which is what exactly is racism
because for example when you saw like
you know Amy Cooper called the cops and
like threatened essentially this black
man's existence a lot of people were
like she's not racist even she came out
it was like I'm not racist which begs a
question of like then what do you think
racism is well yeah and I do think a lot
of white people do think racism is
explicit yeah when really a lot of
racism is microaggression this may be a
little bit more covert like racism
doesn't just exist in somebody looking
at you and saying I don't like you
because you're black that is a very
small level of what it means to be
racist so I'm curious can you tell me
about its time it may be you have
experienced that more covert racism I
know there's tons right but sometimes
that you could pinpoint there I mean
there's plenty there are plenty of times
I don't like to throw around the word
racism loosely because I know to your
point a lot of the person I'm talking to
this white person this probably doesn't
even understand and what
talking about when I say okay that was
racist or you're racist so you know for
me I think every black person has had
you know something like I've been pulled
over because officers in my hometown
thought I was my brother and they
harassed my brother all the time
you know but it's not until they know
that I'm like my head coach in high
school was a sergeant so long as I'm not
named drug him I'm lucky enough to have
that kind of association that I know
they know I have somebody to to protect
you know me but I think you know when it
comes to racism people have to
understand that it has nothing to do
with it can deal with hate but you don't
have to hate people in order to be
racist race has everything to do with
your prejudices and the ability to
exercise some type of power which is why
you hear a lot of black people say black
people can't be racist because it's
because it has everything to do with
power that white woman in the park who's
able to to call the reason she's calling
police in saying a black man is
threatening me is because she knows that
the system is set up in order to react
to that situation if a white woman calls
and says that a black man is threatening
me she knows the type of response that
is going to be given history has shown
that from all the way from Emmett Till
to to Tulsa being turned down because of
allegedly a white woman being assaulted
in an elevator the same thing with
rosewood same thing with the red summer
of 1919 every single time if you kid I
think is well known that white women you
know are protected by any means in this
case in this country and so while you
don't have to be racist or hate black
people you can still utilize a racist
system to your benefit if you ever get
scared or ever just get in a bad mood
and we've seen you know white women
really amusing that system because they
know the system is ready they might not
you know participate in it and they
might not contribute to it but when they
want to tap into it they know it's there
and they've been using it and I think
that is where the racism comes into
there's author's name is Keith layman
he's fantastic and he wrote an
autobiography a really a memoir and it's
called heavy and he
says that the term white privilege that
we use is probably it should be called
white power because it's about this
power that white people have that
enables them to move through life but
calling it privilege almost like
minimizes what it actually is it's
something that you have that I don't
which in turn gives you power over me
and over a lot of things right yeah and
I think that there probably is some some
truth to that I think the reason that is
never going to be the popular term is
because white power also has a different
definition which is maybe a bit elevated
then exchanging it for the word
privilege yeah but I do think if people
realized that racism like you said isn't
just hate it's about power and the way
that you harness that over other
individuals that maybe you don't look
like you it'd be a much better
understanding of how we can navigate
kind of away from that then ideal when
you talk about privilege like that's a
passive term right like I can choose
whether I want to exercise the privilege
or not when we when we talk about it
like hey no you have it you have this
power like that is an active word like
you can and it's loud
we talk about being an ally we don't
want you to to deny that you have white
privilege we don't want you to ignore
your privilege we want you to use it
like you have the power we want you to
either relinquish that power to to you
know elevate somebody who's black or you
know or in that regard or use that power
to break down these systems because you
can't have more power more leverage more
reach and a lot of your black peers and
I think you know it is not a it is not a
crime or an indictment against white
people to acknowledge that you have a
power or privilege you didn't create it
like it was given to you and this point
in time is what do you do with you know
are you using that to advance us as a
people or to keep us you know in a
status quo and I think that's kind of
that it's a responsibility you know it's
hard for people to take that on
especially
as fast as this movement is kind of come
and people have had to kind of process
this but it's gonna come down to if we
want to be better as the country is
going to come down to white people who
have power and who have this privilege
using it to change us because we're the
minority we don't have no boats voices
to do it completely on our own and it's
gonna come down to those allies using
their power and privilege to assist one
of the reasons I asked that question off
top is because you know that moment
where you realize being black is
different it's very commonly referred to
as an awakening and I think a lot of
black people are actually having that
awakening in this moment and which seems
crazy that is crazy but I can tell from
some of these like statements and like
things people are saying that this is
their awakening moment am I alone in
feeling that way or have you felt that
way at all I want to say it's an
awakening it will be hard for me to
really to really and it could be true
but it will hurt it'll be hard for me to
fathom just in my own experience and
background that black people you know
and this moment this is the first time
they recognize that their blackness
means something in this country
everything about our culture is copied
is replicated and he'll don't have a
guard but we are demonized for it like
we have been completely detached from
our you know heritage and Africa and all
of our traditions Bea literally
integrate ourselves into a Western world
and we've made it our own we created you
know great things out of you know this
is simulating but for whatever reason
when you still have that that racism and
Prejudice still around like you you are
constantly putting your head against my
blood what is it like what else do we
have to do in order to be seen as as
true creakle and I think that that we're
at that boiling point where people are
entire tired of assimilating you
starting to see more people you know
look back into their heritage to look
back into history and really try to find
themselves because for us trying to fit
in you know completely into this Western
kind of mentality really
played outside benefit I saw I mean
obviously we know that there has been
awakening for a number of different NFL
players
I think Drew Brees kind of took the
forefront of that when he was getting
some heat rightfully so for the
statement he didn't make when he was
asked about the protests and you also
became a part of that story because you
posted a very powerful video talking
about the situation on your Instagram
drew Brees if you don't understand how
hurtful how insensitive no comments are
you are part of the problem and I mean
in the video it was emotional and you
were crying and I know tears can be the
manifestation of a lot of different
things like what did the tears represent
for you in that video like what emotions
were those tears well honestly I think
you know one thing that it's the only
reason that I posted the video he's good
I don't like being emotional in front of
people that's not not what I'm
comfortable doing but I think people
have to understand how much black people
will carry just kind of underneath their
skin like just on a day to day basis the
things that we put up with that we don't
say the things that we see constantly
and we internalize but you know try to
have to go into a corporate you know
workplace and and still get along I have
to go into these spaces that aren't for
us we aren't represented aren't you know
and make people feel comfortable with
who we are all the time and then for you
know all the things to kind of come to
fruition as they have you know the last
month too that was kind of like it was
hurtful because this is these are people
who you think you know see you for who
you are kind of see your struggles and
recognize it and this it was like you
know frustrating because I'm like if if
the people close
to me don't know what it feels like for
me to be in the skin and like then we
got a long way to go and I think it's
important it was important for not only
drew but everybody who's having these
cut these tough conversations to
understand that these things hurt and
they've been along around for a long
time a lot of this that week
internalized it's not just that it
happened to George Florida in Minnesota
but when we see that constantly I see my
younger brothers I see my cousin's my
uncles my dad like that could easily be
so we see ourselves like dying we see
that trauma and it does something to you
and I don't think that you know a lot of
guys are aware of kind of that burden
that people carry around and we do it
and we still you know keep us smile on
our face and we still create beautiful
things you still have cultural smile but
it's tough and I think the number one
thing you heard people say in the
highest month is like we tired and I
think that's really what that was just
like you know I'm exhausted by holding
this weight that I didn't even put on
myself you know yeah I do think a lot of
people saw the emotion it was like he's
so sad and I was like no I think he's
probably angry and her and it's not like
a sadness as much as it is like
everything that that has come with it
you know it's just been an accumulation
kind of of everything do you think drew
now has a better grasp I do I mean yeah
I do and I think you know I think it
came in in phases I honestly don't think
he really you know necessarily knew what
he wasn't saying and I'm trying to tell
him was like your your thoughts are on
you're open to that opinion I have no
problem with that opinion I was like
nobody's hurt because of how you feel
about flag we actually know that about
you and expect that from you but it's
more about you know acknowledging would
it mean what it may mean to me what it
may not mean to me or what wouldn't if
not even about the flag just about me
it's our demonstration in general would
that's about acknowledging that like
pain or
that great the grievance that I have is
really what it comes down to and I think
obviously with all the backlash but him
talking you know to a lot of the guys
that he's been closest with the guys
he's played with you know long career he
reached out to a lot of us me included
and and I think guys being able to tell
somebody like you reason the truth that
like you your words hurt because of this
like this was you know I think that that
helped him really one realize how deep
it was for his teammates and for other
people that you know didn't share his
experience and I think you know he
understands that sometimes you know
there's opportunity for you to really
just listen and and be a lot more
careful especially as polarized as our
country is you know when leaders come
out and speak you have different
factions trying to attach themselves to
like these figure heads right which we
saw trunk try to jump right on through
comments and I'm glad that drew stood up
to trump and said that one there's
things for him to learn were to like
this
these aren't made-up stories people have
been complaining for centuries that
there's a real issue here and it's time
for us to really truly understand the
depths of the drew brees video ended up
being pretty necessary in a lot of ways
because it kind of served as a catalyst
for some other things obviously we saw a
lot of NFL stars come together and make
the video to Rodrigo you know if Michael
Thomas like when Berkeley Odell
everybody's ripping that video and Roger
Goodell then responded with the video as
well do you feel like that was a genuine
move on the NFL's part I think you know
even if it was and I've said this before
until they address the Colin Kaepernick
thing
nobody's where they're going to like
acknowledge the efforts that come forth
you know they've
giving money in the past they created an
entire fire change things like you know
coming out with statements you know
don't matter what players really want to
see it's like how are you going to
address Colin Kaepernick now that you
had this awakening of you know how you
should have done better and into like
what does that look like not only which
is credit checks for charities but what
is it look like within your hiring
practices there's like four black
coaches and two black gyms like what are
you going to start adding leadership
into the your you know front offices
that's what people want to see the
statements really no don't matter and I
think the more we kind of get caught up
in these statement is like the less time
we actually spend as athletes to talking
about the actual like issues and what we
need to be drawn attention to don't
thank us it's one of those things that
it's
I'd rather them not make statements
because when they do the whole country
focuses back on the NFL what they're
doing when in reality we need it to be
pushing our focus to legislation to this
to getting people registered to vote in
this election that's coming up like
there are so many things that we need to
be focused on and I think every time the
NFL chimes in on you know what's
happening it just leads to more
questions and more scrutiny and more
distractions yeah I mean I will say I
think it's a double-edged sword in a lot
of ways right because I agree and I
commend you on how whenever these things
happen you're like okay what's the
actionable item that's always your thing
what can I do to the hell what can I do
to you know for the Advancement of black
people we have talked at length you know
with like things that you can actually
do and I think that's great and it's
important and it's probably what is the
most important but on the other side one
of the main things for me throughout
this time has been that places and
people need to acknowledge things that
they have done because acknowledgement I
think is a big part of healing for a lot
of people and for me that is what has
been lacking for the NFL is the
acknowledgement because it correct me if
I'm wrong I think the NFL has played a
role in perpetuating either black people
staying stagnant or in perpetuating some
racist ideologies I think it's important
for them to have to say something about
that yeah I think I think if you look at
if you wanted to measure them on the
diversity and their hiring practices
outside of the players I would say that
there's definitely a need for more
diversity and that could be perpetuating
a racist kind of you know organization
not that they don't think they would
consider themselves racist but if you
divide it left my race it's telling I
think if you look at you know obviously
Colin Kaepernick and what he did and
what that in contact now like you have
police officers people taking these all
over the world because it stood for
something I think that they contributed
or loud that message to be muddied up
and now that hurt kind of that movement
and I think they just they just flat-out
old Capra [ __ ] an apology like that's
that's the acknowledgement I think that
that needs to happen yeah cuz you know
that's really what everybody wants to
hear is the rest is cool everybody's
having a wait and I don't think anybody
even like hold you to that but they had
an opportunity to really be out in front
and be proactive and that's the most
unfortunate thing I think about our
league and leadership in our leagues we
haven't really been very proactive when
it comes to things that ill the black
community or really not even a black you
mean just in general we were late on
domestic violence we were late with even
the concussions though they were high in
veins and and so for us I think until
you change up or add some diversity to
your leadership you won't have a
diversity of perspective you'll always
be reacting to especially the black
community because you don't have any
black representation in leadership and
in the ability to you know have a voice
at the table outside of your players and
I think that's really the most telling
thing is is how do you add diversity and
black people to your leadership to
address you know the issues that are you
know plagued in the communities of
seventy percent of your players
absolutely absolutely a couple more for
you obviously you know I think that
right now we're being fed you know a lot
of images and videos that are about
trauma that black people see and
withhold and I think what's getting lost
is that you know there is so much joy in
being black so I want you to tell me
this kind of what do you love about
being black so I think that that's
equally as important yeah I think man
black people are so resourceful creative
you know for us to have so much
you know trauma and be to feel oppressed
and all these things that we have out of
those same you know places to come you
know things that have changed world come
to visions that have changed world
hip-hop in in all the dances that spread
around the world start in our
neighborhoods our art our music like all
of those things the joy and love that we
see within black families back home
black community the way that we interact
with each other that other people
sometimes don't understand is is
something that makes us beautiful and I
love it you know personally and I think
you know for a long time and even still
now when you try to celebrate like your
blackness and be proud of your blackness
sometimes people take that as being you
know anti white or an anti everybody
else and it's like no we have to
understand that black people in our
image how we been depicted for since we
stepped foot in this country has always
made us you know predicted us is less
than people literally in a constitution
were less than a man and so here we are
now in 2020 having to purposely affirm
ourselves having to lift up those things
that are beautiful about us lift up each
other and celebrate our culture around
history on skin on hair dance everything
about it because we know wholeheartedly
that the world will tell us that those
things are not and I think we went
through really a couple generations that
tried to do everything
you know white tried to change the hair
and change the skin color and I think
there's you know this resurgence of this
pride in who we are and I think that is
the essence of being black is to be able
to maintain your joy and be able to
create great things to thrive and have
jewelry regardless of what the
circumstances are around yeah for sure I
think we have a gift to thrive despite
our surroundings and I think that that's
super important and that shouldn't get
lost on anybody I always say it's like
at the end of the day every good quality
about myself I feel like I owe to being
black
and regardless of the you know injustice
that we face or they hate that we may
face I would never want to be anything
else and I truly mean I I don't know
what life is without blackness being at
my core and I try to like implore people
throughout this time to like no matter
remember that because it's so easy to
feel like maybe life could've been easy
if it was this or that but like you'd be
so different and there's so many
positives and so much strength comes
from it and I think I think that's
really important to say as often as we
can that yes we are these things but
were other things too and to not be too
too caught up in that so those words are
great so I'm ending all of these with
the same question just like I begin with
the same one I'm ending with the same as
well so words of course mean different
things to different people how do you
define America I think that is is
changed over the years
I think I see America as a place that
I'm constantly trying to make home
like that's that's how I feel about it
is that you know this
I'm obviously American this is where I
live this is the country I affiliated
with this is why I pay taxes but
something about it it's not quite felt
like you know it's made for me and I'm
and I think a lot of black people can
say that they've been trying to make
this place ours to you know to make sure
that we fight for the same rights
thereby else cuz we built this country
but that is not necessarily reality so
it's home by definition but I'm
constantly trying to make it my home and
that makes any sense now a place we're
always trying to make home for sure
No thank you Mike oh thank you
[Music]